aber wir kriegen ihn sage ich ja alles
klar und das erste mal fünf reihen so
dahinter ist unser erster gegner
getroffen
ich kenne dich gilt es gibt sich servus
s kids und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen videospiel heute mal wieder lucky
blogs bettelei kress awards auf pixel
punkt netz besitzt er rechts und heute
haben wir eine besondere challenge die
ich schon immer mal machen wollte
allerdings ist es jetzt wieder so spät
dass ich die nicht in jumping oder so
was machen kann deswegen machen wir hier
auf pixel denn dass er ein ausländischer
server und da sind auch nachts noch
ziemlich viele spieler wir haben ist
nämlich gerade viertel nach zwei in der
nacht von sonntag auf montag ich bin
heute um zwölf jahre um mitternacht
wieder zurückgekommen aus köln also ich
war in köln hat da mit luca was gemacht
war bei 1 sp poker usw
vom vielleicht ein paar von euch gesehen
dann leisten wenn ja könnte ist immer in
die kommentare schreiben
wenn ich gerade zurückgekommen und
nehmen jetzt natürlich auch ein video
für euch morgen auf dass wir dann morgen
heute sieht es heute dem ich heute am
montag für euch ist heute montag
genaues ist ein bisschen später in der
nacht und wir machen heute die f5
challenge hier in crazy horse das heißt
sobald ich das deathmatch erreiche läuft
diese challenge und die besagt wenn das
wird ziemlich witzig dass ich für jeden
kill den ich mache einmal die f5 taste
drücken muss und ich würde mal behaupten
wenn ich jetzt nicht todes ab skille
dann ist da ziemlich schnell schluss
denn ihr einmal fünf geht noch so kann
man vielleicht auch freiheiten aber
zweimal fünf teils ziemlich sind wie
schnell feierabend aber man kann ja
immer ziemlich viel raus mit equipment
und so deswegen werde ich es auf jeden
fall versuchen und ich würde sagen die
chancen stehen auch gar nicht so
schlecht dass wir da was reißen ja das
war weit von mir ich würde sagen es gibt
mal fort bis hin zu dem zeitpunkt wo die
alles klappt so leute sind wir und auf
und erweitert durch die map geändert
hacks band server wird gewarnt alles
gleich bei den server dass man hier
reinschauen
was haben wir wir haben elf sagte wir
haben 250 redstone 10 goldbarren so als
erstes kommt dieses scharfe schwert ich
weiß viele sagen aber man sollte die
schwerter und kaufen dann entscheiden
man weiß halt nie sicher ob man auch
wirklich scharf drauf bekommt deswegen
mal wenn nicht jetzt diesmal hab dann
kaufe ich mir einfach
okay beim bogen ist bisschen nötig aber
auch so genug verpasst so und jetzt die
frage
ich sage von den zehn gold ich würde
sagen wir holen uns erstmal eine menge
heiltränke weil diese technische richtig
schwer sein wird und gold äpfel so alles
klar
das ist glaube ich die bessere
alternative und jetzt hier unten das
dann noch rein
und jetzt mal die gesamte rüstung
entscheiden vielleicht noch mal ein
shuttle bus mitnehmen
weil wir werden die richtig viel damage
bekommen auf jeden fall ich glaube dass
es besser wenn er einfach ein bisschen
frieden könnt ihr mir weglaufen mit
diesen trinken ist glaube ich die
bessere option würde ich sagen besser
ist dies weil die dir schätzt hoffen
bekommen wir dann hoffentlich von
unserem ersten kill so durchatmen
partners leute vier sekunden bis sie als
fallen stoffen den ball herein und es
geht los
greenworld fordern dass unser erster
gegner hier zack zack zack zack wo der
mattick schaden aber wir kriegen ihn
sage ich ja alles klar und das erste mal
fünf reihen so dahinter ist unser erster
gegner getroffen
doch ich kenne dich gelte es gibt sich
kelly ich berichte gilt alter ok jetzt
ist schwierig jetzt wird richtig
schwierig dass intelligenz nice bekommen
okay wir können auch hier die
schärfewerte tierisch mal kombinieren so
da können jetzt nicht hin
frage ist wohl jetzt der nächste gegner
hatte er kommt kann ja sagt christoph
mahr wisst ihr ich finde auch ja ich
kann für mich gewaltig um die
schleck-gruppe dem schwert virtuell ist
es schärfe hier haltbarkeit speed und
resistance wisst ihr was www gema
erstmal zum shop hier
und zwar so & drop mal hier in meppen
lucky blog für den player hält haben wir
da unten und nochmal einen arm allagui
blog so die welt jetzt schon platziert
sei sei es jeff drei das sieht doch gut
aus
nehmen wir das mal und noch war es ja
mal zeichnet den lucky blog hier den
araki blog place mir auch mal flott und
der drops uns einen schönen helm schutz
drei feuerschutz 3d gastspiele gutes
foul an timo weckmann frage ist bekommen
wir nämlich genug scherfig weiterhin
noch ein chef drei zu machen dann am
ende auf eine schärfe vier zu kommen
aber wisst ihr was wir machen können wir
können eigentlich einmal jede menge
heiltränke und gold äpfel kaufen um es
richtig voll zu schaffen denn jetzt
wird's auf jeden fall knackig ich weiß
nicht mal welche richtung die gegner
sind alter ich weiß nicht in das wird so
schwierig jetzt gerade bei junge aber
die schärfe 33 schwert oh ja ich habe
auch keine ahnung da hin dass eine
erkenntnis
einer der king kongo größer ist ja okay
die spieler angegriffen spiel wusste ich
kann nicht zum gegner laufen
ok kurzum gucken da hinten ist das mega
op aus ob er neben richtig gut an die
macht muss man sagen das war echt nicht
schlecht zu mir zwei gold dafür
gefressene sollte eigentlich nicht
machen
wir haben immer noch nicht genug genug
gold wissen was wir gehen einfach nur
zum shop und kochen sommer was hier
es ist also das move mit dem r 5 modus
ist richtig schwierig würde ich mal
behaupten ihr werdet sehen ist das mal
ausprobiert der ok die sechs gold apple
alles klar
ich würde sagen wir probieren jetzt mal
so aus also irgendwie kämpfen können
wenn wir aber merken das ist so einfach
nicht geht dann zwischen ja in den aua
alte ross das wird schwer denn ja okay
es geht es gut es geht nicht es geht
nicht dann zwischen den einfachen 5
modus soll ich sagen
mein ding so und zwar in den hier so
dass die er 15 ist wahr sie bestehen
bleibt aber wir es nicht komplett
unmöglich haben so das ist wenn jemand
ziemlich alter mann dieser server man
kriegt so die verrücktesten hits einfach
aus 1000 blöcken entfernung treffen die
einen noch das gibts echt nicht dass es
beim schwert immer richtig ärgerlich
wenn das einer border selling weil ich
glaube so leute so kann man einfach
nicht kämpfen
das geht einfach nicht ihr könnt
natürlich selbst mal ausprobieren und
dann in die kommentare schreiben
bei euch ausgehen
mache ihm schon okay okay wir machen
ganz gut schaden glaube ich
moussa koussa weg er muss auch weg muss
auch wenn wir bleiben dran
alter schwede harten punch bogen fahren
ist ja egal du wirst nicht erwischt in
mein lieber nicht sehr schön schärfe
drei schwer zahlt sich aus erwischt und
sicher bestimmt sich fünf läuft
weiterhin nein jungen alters ohne
garantiert alter gesamtplan sprung
rettet ihn jetzt ganz schönen arsch hier
gerade alter okay jetzt warum hat jetzt
wieder so viele leben das gibt's ja
nicht das gibt es nicht wir kommen gut
weg ist weg des weg das weckte okay es
weg junge wie kraft erst richtig richtig
spielt darum gegangen richtig langsam
ich dachte schon das war's für mich
aber erstmal hier schön den ganzen diaz
darf einpacken das sieht doch gut aus so
alter schön stärke 2 schlag zwei bogen
der probleme gemacht und ich hab's gar
nicht gecheckt während die runde moment
mal
alter schwede wir haben die runde
gewonnen das war unser letzter gegner
wir haben drei kills gemacht alter jetzt
gar nicht geteilt wenn die runde
gewonnen
ihr alter sehr schön perfekt leute
schreibt eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare wie das mit der fünfter ist
kann man überhaupt zu spielen wenn man
quasi im zweiten 5 modus ist ich glaube
nicht was denn ihr unten rein lassen da
wir sind beim nächsten mal wieder dran
hat gut und